ومن المهم أن نعرف أن
سبعة صحفيين على الأقل قتلوا
في غزة منذ يوم السبت وفقًا
للجنة العلاقات العامة لحماية الصحفيين،
فلننتقل الآن إلى الجراح الفلسطيني البريطاني
رسان أبو الذي غادر لندن إلى
غزة يوم الأحد حيث كان من الواضح ما كان
يحدث بعد ذلك.  أن المذبحة في إسرائيل قد
قُتل فيها 1300 شخص
وفقًا للمسؤولين الإسرائيليين ولكن
دعني أسألك لأننا نريد أن نعرف
ما الذي يحدث وكيف يمكنك
المساعدة كطبيب جاء من الخارج
لمساعدة هؤلاء المدنيين بوضوح من
أنت  تعرف بوضوح أنك ستصاب
وتقتل ما الذي تمكنت من فعله
لهم حتى الآن يا
دكتور المشكلة هي الحجم الهائل
أه الكارثة التي حلت بغزة
6500 جريح في 6 أيام في مكان تبلغ
سعة السرير الإجمالية
2500 هذا  إنه أمر مرهق تمامًا
للنظام الصحي الذي كان بالفعل على
ركبتيه في نهاية 15 عامًا من
الحصار. أم النظام الصحي غير قادر
على التأقلم أه نحن نفتقد المواد الاستهلاكية على
نفس المادة التي تحتاجها لتكون
قادرًا على علاج المرضى سواء كانوا  عبارة عن
ضمادات أو أه معدات تخدير أو
يمكن التخلص منها والقدرة الاستيعابية
لغرفة العمليات في معظم
مستشفيات غزة غير قادرة على التعامل مع
العدد الهائل من المرضى الذين يحتاجون
للذهاب إلى غرف العمليات
والمرضى الذين هم الآن في حالة حرجة
و  بحاجة إلى وحدة العناية المركزة
أه دكتور رسان هل يمكنك أن تخبرني ما
هو التأثير وهل تشعر به بعد من
الحصار كما
أعلن وزير الدفاع الإسرائيلي قبل بضعة أيام بينما
كنت أتحدث للتو مع أحد كبار
مستشاري الحكومة حول ما تعرفه عن  الطعام،
الوقود، الماء، هل لديك ما يكفي من
الماء، هل لدى الناس طعام، هل سينفد،
لذا فإن الشيء الذي تلاحظه أكثر عندما
تكون في المستشفى هو غياب المعدات
الطبية الأساسية أه الاحتياجات أه المعدات التي
تحتاجها لتكون قادرًا  لعلاج المريض
أه أيضا كل المستشفيات الآن تعتمد
اعتمادا كليا على المولدات
الكهربائية والديزل من
الأشياء التي لا تأتي الآن
نتيجة هذا
الحصار الشامل أه ترى أه أه خزانات المياه هذه
التي يتم  اه يصل
للمنازل والمستشفيات اه على مدار الساعة
بالرغم من أن هناك
قصف متواصل أم الطعام في
الوقت الحالي ليس قليل ولكن هناك أكثر من
250 ألف شخص نازح الكثير منهم
الآلاف يعيشون في مجمع
مستشفى OFA المستشفى الرئيسي في غزة  أو
مع أقاربهم ولذلك فقد هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
فقدوا منازلهم
قدرتهم على إعالة أنفسهم وإطعام
أنفسهم، ولذا فإن ما ننظر إليه
هو كارثة، كارثة من صنع الإنسان تشبه
تقريبًا
عاصفة كاملة  الناس نزحوا منازلهم
دمرت نظام صحي معطل
نتيجة للحصار والأعداد تتجاوز
قدرة النظام الصحي على
التعامل
مع هذا الأمر، هل يمكنني أن أسألك شيئًا أم أنك
أتيت بطريقة ما إلى غزة من
المملكة المتحدة؟  لنفترض أن حدود رفح من الجانب المصري،
وأنت تعلم أن
إسرائيل طلبت من الناس المغادرة، فقط
غادروا، ابحثوا عن مأوى، غادروا، هل هناك
حركة مرور في الاتجاهين، هل يستطيع الأشخاص المغادرة،
وكنت قادرًا على
الدخول، لذلك كنت جزءًا من المجموعة الأخيرة  من
هذا النوع من الأشخاص دخلوا صباح يوم الاثنين في
الساعات الأولى من صباح يوم الاثنين
وأعتقد أنه بعد وقت قصير من قيام
القوات الجوية الإسرائيلية بقصف المنطقة المحيطة بـ را
وأجبرتها على الإغلاق أه لم يكن هناك
أحد بالداخل وبالتأكيد لم يخرج أحد
منذ ذلك الحين  إذن أعتقد أن معبر رع
مغلق منذ
ذلك الحين وأخبرني أه ما الذي دفعك
للذهاب إلى هناك وهل فعلت ذلك
من قبل في مناطق الحرب الأخرى
لذلك أنا زرت
حروب غزة في هجوم 2009 على  غزة 2012 و
14 و
2021 ام وعملت في الموصل عملت
في اليمن عملت في دمشق اه
انا
جراح تجميل وترميم لقد اكتسبت على مر السنين
خبرة في جراحة الحرب و و
كفلسطيني، أنا مدفوع إلى
العودة باستمرار
ومساعدة شعبي هنا الذين يتعرضون
لهجوم مستمر وكشخص
عمل في النظام الصحي في غزة، فأنا
أدرك تمامًا النقص الكامل فيما
يتعلق  المعدات والخبرة والمواد
الموجودة في
النظام، وهل يمكنك أن تخبرني ما هو نوع
الإصابات التي تراها أكثر من غيرها،
أعلم أنك تحدثت عن الحروق دون أن
يكون لديك حتى المطهر المناسب
لفرك الحروق قبل العلاج  لكن
ما هي الإصابات الأخرى التي
تعالجونها إذًا عندما تكون
الغالبية العظمى من الجرحى قادمين من تحت أنقاض
منازلهم وهذا
يعني أن ما بين 30 إلى 40% من
الجرحى هم من الأطفال ويصابون
بالانفجار أه
شظايا أه  البناء الذي يتطاير في أه أه
ويتلف أجسادهم أو يتم
سحقهم تحت أنقاض
منزلهم أه فكل هذه الإصابات
ملوثة للغاية وتتطلب
عمليات جراحية وعمليات جراحية متكررة والمدمر
مع الأطفال
أه هذا هو العمر  أه تستحق
الجراحة الترميمية حيث أن ذلك الجسد
المتضرر الذي يحاول أن ينمو في المستقبل
سيحتاج هؤلاء الأطفال إلى عملية جراحية بعد
الجراحة كما رأينا مع الأطفال في
حروب غزة السابقة أو في سوريا أو في
اليمن أو في أي مكان
يصاب فيه الأطفال  هذا
الصراع وأخيراً دكتور راسانا، ماذا
عن العائلة، هل لديك بالفعل عائلة
هناك في غزة في
المنطقة
هناك، لذا كانت عائلتي لاجئة أه أه
جعلت لاجئين في غزة عام 48 أه
على الرغم من أن والدي آه غادر غزة في
الخمسينيات  وانتقلت إلى الكويت لا يزال لدي
أبناء عمومة يعيشون في غزة وأصهار
يعيشون في غزة أم في أول يوم
وصول ذهبت إلى منزل عمي الأكبر
أه أم وكان لا بد من إخلائنا
في اليوم الأول لأن المنطقة  تم
استهدافنا، فانتقلنا إلى
منزل ابن عم آخر وتم احتجازنا
في الليلة الأولى من القصف
ولم أتمكن من الوصول إلى مستشفى الشفاء
حتى صباح يوم الثلاثاء آه آه عندما
عدت لأخذ أغراضي من
منزل عمي  اكتشفنا أن
المنزل قد تعرض لأضرار جسيمة
لأن الحي بأكمله قد تعرض
للقصف في ذلك
المساء